You are watching a video.
Right now.
This is a video.
You’re probably watching on your TV at home,
on your computer at the office, or on your
phone while sitting on the toilet.
While you watch, every second, there are millions
of pixels lighting up your screen with high-definition
images with rich stereo sound, both coded
with billions of bits streaming to you through
the internet.
Mobile devices, smart TVs, and easy access
to high-speed internet have made this all
seem common.
Trivial, even.
But the magic of how these images and sounds
are coming to you, instantly, just about anywhere,
is a pretty incredible feat of engineering.
The technology has become so commonplace that
the appearance of a buffering symbol, even
on mobile internet, is considered a failure
of the streaming service.
A problem we had to contend with while building
our own streaming service Nebula.
And, as Wendover Productions did before me
in telling the story of why Nebula exists,
I’m telling the story of HOW it exists,
and because it’s something I helped build,
I am speaking directly to camera for the first
time.
When we started out, Nebula didn’t have
a dedicated staff of engineers — it was
an experimental side-project — so we built
the first version on Zype, which offers white-label
streaming video services.
Using their tools, we had a full, worldwide
service up and running in just a few months.
The problem was that Zype wasn’t built to
handle the complexities of running hundreds
of channels, or releasing hundreds of videos
per month, or streaming to hundreds of thousands
of active subscribers.
As Nebula outgrew them, we knew we needed
to build something fully custom, from the
ground up.
A streaming system we named “Starlight.”
From the software that compresses and delivers
the video to servers around the world, to
the apps and browsers you watch them on, and
the internet in between, this technology has
advanced drastically in the last decade.
This is how it works.
If you were born after the year 2000, streaming
video might not seem like a big deal, but
in the early Internet days of the 1990s, streaming
a video was basically unthinkable.
In 1999, the trailer for Star Wars Episode
1: The Phantom Menace broke records by being
downloaded over one million times in 24 hours.
Downloaded, not streamed, because streaming
a movie trailer at any level of quality simply
wasn’t possible for the dial-up modem connection
speeds common at the time.
In those days, most people connected to the
Internet using their telephone lines.
Incredibly slow internet that was measured
in the kilobits per second, not the mega and
giga bits we are accustomed to today.
Those modems worked through modulation of
a digital signal onto the analog sound signal
being transferred over the copper telephone
wires.
If the amplitude of the sound was high, it
was a binary 1, if the amplitude was low,
it was a 0.
The transmitting computer would modulate the
data into sound waves, and the receiving computer
would demodulate.
Modulate, demodulate.
“Modem.”
To an extent, this is how most physical cables
work, short of fiber optics.
But doing this over copper telephone lines
is prone to loss, so the fastest speed you
could possibly hope to get in the best of
conditions was 56 kilobits per second.
For comparison, even a 720p YouTube video
has a bitrate of 5 megabits per second.
Around 90 times faster than a dial-up modem
could receive.
By 2005, broadband connections like cable
modems were much more common, providing the
infrastructure for three guys in northern
California to start a video dating service
called “YouTube.”
That year, when Justin Timberlake and Janet
Jackson had their infamous “wardrobe malfunction”
at the Super Bowl halftime show, the trio
realized they couldn’t find any video of
the incident online, and repurposed YouTube
to be a digital video repository that anyone
could use.
Nearly two decades later, home Internet speeds
have advanced significantly, but more crucially,
mobile Internet connections have gotten so
fast that they often rival dedicated home
connections.
The smartphone revolution has driven cellular
data speeds to insane new levels, adding more
and more frequencies and ways to squeeze more
data onto them.
We now have the technologies to send the data
over long distances quickly, but that’s
just part one of the problem.
When you clicked on this video you expected
to play immediately, without buffering.
That can happen if the video is stored on
a server near you and you are one of the privileged
people to have access to fast internet, but
that isn’t always the case, and solving
those edge cases is where smaller indie streamers
like Nebula need to play it smart.
The primary constraint is bandwidth.
While high-speed connections are common in
the western world, not all users will have
fast internet access, and even if they do
have fast access network, problems can still
occur which may lead to degraded performance.
A poorly-shielded microwave can interfere
with Wi-Fi, Internet service providers may
have temporary slowdowns during times of peak
usage, and going through a subway tunnel on
your morning commute may cause you to intermittently
lose signal
To help combat these inconsistencies, the
server will encode the video several times
with different bitrates.
Bitrate simply means the speed at which the
video will need to be transmitted in order
to avoid buffering or pauses.
Once the transcoder limits the bitrate, it
will also need to lower the resolution of
the video to keep the overall visual quality
of the video watchable.
Low bitrates combined with high resolution
result in blocky video that is very distracting.
The transcoder creates files with different
bitrates and resolution pairings, producing
low-quality smaller files all the way up through
larger 4K files.
When a video player is streaming a video,
it isn’t downloading the entire file at
once, it downloads chunks at a time.
This allows for changes in streaming quality
during playback.
If your internet connection slows down, the
service can switch to the lower-resolution
version of the file on-the -fly.
The video may not look as good, but it’ll
keep playing, and hopefully switch back later
when the connection improves.
It also allows for starting playback in the
middle of a video; if you want to pick up
a video where you left off yesterday, there’s
no need to download the entire file.
Plus, since most videos don’t get watched
to 100% completion, this approach also saves
countless dollars on bandwidth bills.
For Nebula’s “Starlight” system, the
team uses fragmented MP4s for this packaging.
This lets us separate the audio files from
the video.
Audio requires much smaller file sizes compared
to video, and studies have shown that poor
audio quality will impact the viewer’s experience
more than poor video quality In other words,
a bad-sounding video will look worse.
By separating audio and video, the team ensures
that the audio quality remains the same between
all resolutions.
Once the files are split, text manifests are
written to describe the precise timing and
file location for every chunk of video.
These manifests are what the video players
read when they load a video
Once the central servers have finished processing
the new files, it needs to store them across
multiple different servers to ensure there
is a copy near the viewer.
There’s a popular misconception that storage
and bandwidth are the expensive parts of running
a streaming service.
While file storage was once very expensive,
modern services like Amazon Web Services S3
and Backblaze B2 provide pretty inexpensive
storage.
Around 3.7 million new videos are uploaded
to YouTube every day, so we imagine their
storage cost is higher than ours, but they
also own all of their data centers.
We think it’s safe to say that YouTube probably
pays less per video for storage than Nebula
does, but for context, Nebula’s entire catalog
is currently around 30 terabytes.
We pay less than $200 USD per month to store
it.
That’s less than I pay for my production
team's adobe subscriptions.
With the files transcoded, packaged, and stored,
the next step is to deliver them to viewers.
When a user requests to watch a video, the
service could serve it to them directly from
storage, but depending on where in the world
the viewer lives, that might be a slow process.
This is why we need a CDN.
CDN stands for content delivery network.
This is a network of servers all over the
world, spaced out specifically to ensure that
there’s a server near any given video viewer.
When you tap to watch a video, the service
matches you to the CDN server closest to you
and starts the stream.
The previous steps were all just preparation
to ensure that this local server had what
it needed.
CDNs have the capacity to transfer the 2,000+
terabytes of video data Nebula delivers every
month.
The CDN Nebula uses, Fastly, uses a 2-step
caching system utilizing three sets of servers.
First there’s the local servers, called
“nodes”.
These are ideally located very close to you.
When your app or browser requests a video,
the service first checks for the files at
your local node.
If it doesn’t find them, it checks the caching
servers.
The caching servers act as a second layer
of temporary storage.
They contain all of Nebula’s catalog of
videos, allowing them to serve nodes in their
region quickly.
Finally, there’s the Origin — the data
center with the servers and hard drives containing
all of the original transcoded videos.
Duplicating every video file on every node
around the world would take up a lot of space
and use a lot of bandwidth, so the system
prioritizes newer, high-demand videos.
If a video is especially popular, there’s
a good chance that someone in your geographical
region has beaten you to watching it first.
If the video is older and less popular, the
chances that it has that initial buffering
time is higher.
It’s a lot like how retail supply chain
works.
Items are produced at the factory (The Origin),
shipped to a warehouse (the caching servers),
and then distributed to local stores (the
nodes) for quick, convenient access.
If you experience stuttering or lag or general
poor video performance, this is often the
root cause.
The video files are served to the CDN nodes
on-demand.
If you’re using a service with millions
or billions of users, you’ll likely never
be the first person to want to watch a particular
video.
For a smaller service like Nebula, if you
live in an area where there aren’t many
subscribers, you’re more likely to end up
waiting for that first transfer more often.
As Nebula grows, this becomes, counter-intuitively,
less of a problem.
Nebula is growing incredibly quickly.
We have more than doubled our direct subscribers
in 2023.
I mentioned earlier that there’s a misconception
about storage and bandwidth being the expensive
parts.
We could only guess what someone like YouTube
pays for bandwidth and delivery for their
videos, but for comparison, as of September
of 2023 Nebula currently has around 300,000
active monthly users, and spends less than
$20,000 per month on bandwidth to serve all
of them.
The biggest hard cost for a streaming service
is hiring talented engineers.
Building this complex system requires frontend
and backend web engineers to create the API
and build the website, development operations
people to make sure the systems are all healthy
and running correctly, quality assurance people
to help find bugs in the code before it ships,
and countless product designers and app developers
to bring the experience to all of the devices
you want to watch videos on.
To get a video playing on your screen, you
need an app with a video player.
Sometimes this happens in a web browser, and
sometimes it happens in a dedicated app.
For most Internet-enabled systems there’s
a client and a server.
The client is the program making the requests,
and the server is the system that answers
those requests.
Most modern software is written so that the
majority of the logic and processing happens
on the server side, not in the client.
This helps to simplify development across
devices.
If there are going to be any major, showstopper
software bugs, it’s better to have them
happen on the server, where the engineers
and development operations teams can quickly
roll out fixes without needing to go through
an app approval process or release new updates.
For a video service, the server sends a list
of videos and all of the thumbnails to go
with it, and the client app renders those
into some kind of human-readable list for
you to browse through.
There are different kinds of apps.
Web apps, mobile apps, desktop apps, TV apps.
Different devices will often require that
apps be written in completely separate programming
languages —
like Swift for iOS, Kotlin for Android, or
JavaScript and TypeScript for smart TV, and
even incredibly niche languages like Brightscript
for Roku,
which makes hiring even more difficult.
To confuse matters further, many of these
devices will require that apps be distributed
through proprietary app stores with their
own approval processes.
When Nebula launched the LG Smart TV app earlier
this year, it took months to get it approved
on the store.
And, quick update, while we were working on
this video, LG told us that Nebula's LGBTQ
content was a violation of their content policy
and the app needed to be removed in 46 countries.
We asked for clarity on this policy, but were
only told that it was for "religious and cultural
elements" in those countries.
We're not really sure why they didn't remove
it themselves, and they haven't responded
to our requests for further discussion.
Regardless of the outcome, having these conversations
and jumping through these hoops consumes a
lot of resources and is generally just a pain
in the ass.
This is just one of the many apps we had to
develop.
Getting approval for iPhone updates, however,
typically happens in a matter of hours.
Catering to each user's watching habits was
an expensive start up cost in development.
While Nebula has only recently started tracking
watch time by device, nearly half of all YouTube
views happen on TV screens.
If any streaming service wants to hold your
attention, it needs to be available no matter
how you want to watch, and that means supporting
a wide variety of options.
Native mobile apps enable you to download
videos to watch offline, in case you’re
on a long flight without Wi-Fi.
TV apps make for comfortable viewing in your
living room.
Web apps mean access from any device with
a web browser, which can have some surprising
results.
Nebula even has a small number of viewers
who watch from the web browser in their Teslas.
It can be tricky to account for all of the
variables in this equation.
Different devices running different operating
systems running apps written in different
languages, with different screen sizes and
design requirements, communicating over connections
that could range from high-speed fiber optics
to a spotty cellular signal in an airport
bathroom.
When you open your phone to watch a video,
what you’re really launching is a massively
complex system that depends on a team of incredibly
skilled software engineers and designers who
not only make all of this possible across
all of these scenarios, but make it look easy.
Nebula is built as a partnership between the
platform and the creators.
The company provides the business structure,
design, and engineering that make up the platform,
and the creators bring their videos and creative
vision.
The platform will never be complete — that’s
the nature of software — but this partnership
has already led to a stable ecosystem.
Nebula has hundreds of thousands of subscribers,
and the number two subscriber retention stats
of any streaming service, second only to Netflix.
This retention is possible because our audience
really cares about the creators and believes
in what we're building.
We respond by making increasingly better videos
for them to watch, which gives them a reason
to stay.
It’s a virtuous cycle.
It's a very different kind of audience relationship,
and we want to safeguard that relationship
and ensure Nebula stays true to the people
who supported it from day one.
That’s difficult to do when you take investment
from venture capital firms.
We don’t want to do that and that limits
us in some ways.
For a subscription business, the key is to
find a balance between cash and revenue.
Cash is money you have today.
Revenue is money that comes in over time.
If we were a VC-funded startup, we'd have
a bunch of cash and we'd spend it on things
we hope would bring in more revenue later,
like funding originals.
But we aren’t VC backed.
We are fan supported.
So instead of sacrificing the platforms autonomy
to shadowy figures in Silicon Valley.
We turned to our most loyal subscribers.
The truth is that we have 680,000 customers.
We can see from our retention stats that many
of them have no intention to cancel their
subscription.
So, why not offer them a way to purchase a
lifetime subscription?
If every single one of those subscribers purchased
a lifetime subscription for say, 300 dollars,
we would have 204 million dollars in the bank
to fund the projects they signed up to watch.
So, that’s what we did, and it has allowed
us to raise capital without turning to venture
capital firms.
You can buy a lifetime subscription right
now.
That program was incredibly successful for
us.
It turns out a lot of people don’t like
having recurring subscriptions every month
and would prefer to just pay once upfront
for lifetime access.
And we have used that funding to greenlight
a lot of really exciting projects.
Including some from our team, that we can’t
yet announce.
That’s unheard of for a streaming platform.
It’s blurring the lines between Hollywood
and creator owned businesses.
We have even greenlit entire movies that our
creators have written, like Patrick Willems
and Abigail Thorne.
That’s ultimately our goal.
To give our creators opportunities that they
traditionally can't get, because some guy
in LA won’t even let them in the room.
This is where the line between educational
video and ad becomes blurry, so I am going
to demarcate it.
This channel depends on the funding Nebula
provides us.
If you have been subscribed to this channel
for more than 3 years, you have seen the huge
increases in production quality that Nebula
has facilitated.
We first started using 3D animations in the
logistics of d-day nebula original series.
Those were all done within after effects,
which is extremely limited in 3D animation.
Then we upgraded to blender and cinema 4D,
thanks to increased revenue driven by Nebula
sponsorships.
Now I think it's fair to say that we are a
world class engineering animation studio.
Just look at our recent Space Shuttle series
for proof of that.
We are committed to continuing that trend.
Investing more and more into our production
quality.
Because I won’t be happy until we are THE
best engineering film studio on the internet.
So please consider signing up for Nebula,
or even better switching to a lifetime membership.
In the run up to the holidays we are also
offering gifted lifetime subscriptions.
So you can gift Nebula to a friend or loved
one this Christmas.
Of course, the regular monthly and yearly
options are still available too.
You can sign up to a monthly, yearly or lifetime
membership with the link in the description
or sign up by pressing the button on screen
now.